like like do you know lucky we are that
we are the rhinoceros or a plant or a
[ __ ] tree like like okay so let's
start with that it's actually almost
impossible to become a human next
there's a billion seven billion of us
right you [ __ ] got lucky enough that
you were born in the number one [ __ ]
place called America that's just real
and just truth it's just true this is
like this can make it's funny I've done
this at different versions for some I'm
going through it this way I'm telling
you this is gonna be one of the things
three or four of you are gonna like live
off of because it's kind of weirdly what
I think I live off of cool now you're in
America [ __ ] lotto it is [ __ ]
insane
you absolutely buy no question have won
the lotto now your parents might have
been [ __ ] up you might have been born
in a you know poor in a [ __ ] area
there's plenty other things there's all
these variables but it's undeniable to
understand the following which is the
single variable that allows me to that a
human being in a heartbeat is how much
they complain I can tell you right now
that the quickest tell to me in the
world that you're not a winning player
is that you complete it's the quickest
he'll like how to beaters after talk
bunch of people guys and gals together
bless you my man I quickly pay attention
to where people go with their content
complaining is literally a zero return
investment and it is stunning to me how
many of you do it
you